[Applause]
another beautiful Savannah morning at
Disney's Animal Kingdom theme park
[Music]
like every day the residents are hungry
basically my job is one of the cooler
jobs
I'm a team I get to feed everybody today
with over 100 animals on the Savannah
Rory and the rest of the Care team have
their hands full
got one of our Springbok do you want to
come up too you're a good girl
do you want some produce
hey come here oh you're such a good girl
you're such a good girl each one out
here has a special place in Rory's heart
hello ladies
oh you're all right
are you good girl
but there's one Savannah species he
really dotes on
let's see what the giraffe are up to
foreign
training giraffe now for about six years
and I've been trained by some giraffe
not too long ago Rory worked with his
giraffe BFF Kenya to voluntarily
position herself for a hoof trip food
that's a good girl come on might be here
a while Kenya tested the team's patience
for eight months
progress was
slow
good afternoon Kenya let's rock and roll
show your stuff honey
hey there we go
that was awesome
[Music]
I'd say I'm psyched
so we're really lucky here to be a part
of the massage giraffe species survival
plan
if you're ever actually undergoing
something called a silent Extinction the
last 40 or so years a large percentage
of their wild population has decreased
and not a lot of people are aware of
that
we're helping people learn every truck
that's going through the Safari the
driver is trying to teach them about
conservation
you know if you can hit one person on
one truck
you're talking about all the trucks that
are going through every day if those
people can go home and talk to somebody
it's a conservation win
I gotta go back to work
so we actually have from left to right
we got Mara Humphrey Lily Jabari Maple
and Isla and then Kenya is all the way
in the back and Willow is all the way
over there you can actually barely see
her she looks like a tree which is a
great example of their camouflage
[Music]
they look pretty different at least to
me if you say so Rory
step one when feeding the supermodels of
the Savannah Runway
entice them with something tasty
every day our animal Nutrition Center
delivers a thousand pounds of brows
today we've got acacia
and then this is what some of our
giraffes really really love and we'll
mix it up with the acacia this is
iliocarpus or a Japanese blueberry
browse is great for us because not only
are they eating the leaves but they're
eating sticks that are green like this
and then they're also stripping the bark
so it's really important for their
dental hygiene and also just their
natural stimuli of their brain
so I made up that bundle I had it in the
back of the truck and I'm ready to hang
it
that's all it takes
[Music]
when they're moving their mouth like
this this is her chewing her cud this is
her digestive system doing its job
when I see a giraffe chewing its cud I
am seeing a happy giraffe
giraffes have a really interesting
digestive system they're ruminants
they need to keep their stomach going
so we need to offer them food at all
times
but Kenya Mara and the rest of the herd
can't rely on appetizers alone
so the team offers an all-day buffet
with everything they need we just hung
some brows we tried to throughout the
day feed them their pellet diet which is
their primary source of all their
nutrition and we have these hanging bins
in the trees
[Music]
all right we'll give her a little extra
goodies in there
[Music]